on va faire une harvey view vous auriez
aimé ressembler à qui quand vous étiez
petit mon père sans doute
ouais tout simplement après si vous me
demandez quel homme que j'admire le plus
winston churchill way we votre plus
belle histoire d'amour c'est quoi la
première la toute toute première j'avais
16 ans a elle aussi
ouais et nous étions tous neufs tous les
deux c'était sécurité ça pas pour ta
femme qui appréciera au chili c'est plus
je suis archi divorce et que vous
changeriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique je serai je serai
moins - tours ou plus plus rond plus
plus malins ouais tu pas si on a joué un
bon je suis pas un courtisan
vous pourriez dire quoi de plus négatif
sur vous il vient de le faire le plus
négatif que je suis plus est parfois
trop trop confiance en moi et trop
confiance en ce que je crois et donc je
pèche parfois par orgueil warhawk ans si
notre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi c'est difficile j'aurais
pu j'aurais j'adore la plongée moi aussi
j'aurais pu avoir une vie complètement
différente en faisant de la plongée
sous-marine biologie vous dire que j'en
ai fait l'archéologie sous marine la
photo sous-marine
mais malheureusement je rêve banc à une
vie à la thalassa une ville à nicolas
hulot vrai ça m'aurait permis de sur la
même chose mais en regardant non pas les
gouvernements et les guerres mais
uniquement la nature et c'est quand même
plus sympa tu chasses aussi oui j'adore
ça et tu pourquoi parce que celle
actuelle et des aliments non
ce qui est intéressant c'est ce qui est
intéressant dans la chasse et la chasse
c'est celle approche c'est de devenir
soi-même animal pour approcher un animal
sauvage c'est sec la finalité mais je me
suis mis à l'arc donc il faut maintenant
les grosses bourdes
on s'est repris trois canards j'ai donné
à l'arc à battre quelle insulte qui vous
a fait le plus mal